- I invited her into my boudoir,
AKA "the stabbin' cabin".
We disrobed one another. I
touched her on her genitalia
she touched me on my man-italia
and that's when I hit it.
Sexually, of course
(music)
- Sexually.
- (Women moaning)
- (Music)
- Ohhhhh, (laughs nervously)
Hi!
Wasn't expecting to see you
all undulating up here? I,
I just put my jacket on the bed
when I first came to the party,
but I didn't realize
that the party made its
way up here, but I'll
get that now. I will.
If you, Carol, I don't know
if you're in there somewhere,
but wherever you are. Thank
you for the invitation.
I really enjoyed myself. I'll
see you at work tomorrow.
Okay. Hey sir.
I think I see my jacket. I think,
I think your arm is in
the sleeve actually.
I'll grab -
That's not my jacket
and that's not your arm.
Its not your arm. White people are crazy.
White people are crazy. Just
looking for a jacket, sir.
Okay. Yeah.
Very nice mustache. I've
never seen one above the nose.
That's interesting. That's not your nose.
Okay. Sorry to disturb you sir,
just looking for a jacket.
Just a ordinary man, looking for a jacket.
You want to say something to me, sir?
Are you try-?
(indistinct) Mmmm
Nope. Thank you very much, sir.
It tasted a little bit like
salted [BEEP], but that's okay.
It's tweed, the jacket I'm talking about
and it's got leather patches on it.
Just, oh, maybe this is it.
Thank you. Found it.
And Nope, that's not it,
but congratulations, ma'am.
You are all doing great with
what God gave you. Nope.
Don't look at me in the eyes.
Ma'am I don't want you to steal my soul.
Hi, ladies.
And nice to meet you. And sir.
Yes, I do see you too.
Okay. Yeah.
White people are crazy. Oh no.
I'm okay. I really am.
I'm already seeing a group of people
and we are taking it slowly
we are taking it slowly. It's a church.
Maybe some of y'all would be
interested in looking into that.
Not mine, but one somewhere if that's-
Okay! Thank you.
Ma'am for the- there it is.
I found it! found the
jacket. It's right here.
Imma pull it and I
believe it might be lodged
somewhere within ya'.
I'm just guessing because
that is just a little bit of resistance.
All right. There we go.
And you know what?
That is going to be yours. Keep it.
Thank you. Cover yourself up.
Carol. if you're in there, I'll see you
at the office tomorrow.
Just bring the bowl. You
can finish the egg salad.
My God white people craz-
(Shuts door)
(Soft music)
(Snaps)
- Hey bro
- What?
- Fuck yeah, lock 'em.
Lock 'em.
Yeahhhhhhhh.
[BEEP] Yeah bro
How awesome is this?
- It's cool
- [BEEP] Yeah, it is.
Hit it, hit it, hit it, hit it.
Yeahhhhhhh.
Dude, synchronize, synchronize.
Get in there, get that, get-
now we're doing it, now we're
doing it, now we're doing it.
Doing it with my bro,
doing it with my bro.
I love every second of
- All right this ones pretty awesome
- You love it?
- Hey can you just-
- OK, yo yo, right there man.
Just give me five.
- Ughh.
- Give me five, bro.
Dumb as [BEEP], pus-[Beep], come on.
Come onnnnn.
Oh you with me now.
- No
- You are with me.
- That's disturbing.
- Keep 'em locked, keep 'em locked.
You ain't going no where.
Give me five.
- Mh-mm.
- Give me five.
- Give- get it- uh ohhhhhhhh.
- Oh, Jesus.
- Dudeeeee, how are we going
to break the world record,
if you can't keep it up?
(Happy Music)
- Oh damn!
Check that [BEEP] out
- What issssss that?
- Hoooo I didn't know
they made 'em like that.
- I don't even understand what I'm seeing.
- Mmm woooohooo.
I would love to see what's under there.
- I am really curious about that.
- Yeah, dawg, yeah.
- I mean I have no idea.
- Well, you know, we, we obviously
have some idea, you know.
- I don't.
- Well, you know, it's, you
know, it's a coochie baby.
- Yeah.
Or something.
- Ahh, nah, nah, nah man.
It's it's it's definitely her lady parts.
- Or maybe it's just more skin.
- Nope.
It's a vagina.
- Yeah.
Or maybe it's a little face under there.
- Uh, no, no.
It's it's definitely gonna be a vagina.
- Why?
- Because she's a girl and
girls have vaginas, man.
- What is that?
- What is a vagina?
It's a woman's reproductive organ.
What are you being serious right now?
- Thank you, that is all I require.
- There's aliens, there's
an alien down there.
- I want to know what's
going on with the huge woman.
And I want to know what the
deal is with the red witch lady
- Yes, yes, yes.
- You know what I'm saying?
Just scream it out
- [Lady 1] Have you ever
slept with a black guy?
- [Lady 2] Noooo but I really want to.
- [Lady 1] Me tooooo!
- Apparently, it is like
a whole other thing than
sleeping with white men.
- [Lady 2] Oh no, no.
I heard they're supposed
to be like way better
at it or something.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
- [Lady 1] I heard that too.
And I wonder if it's cause they have like,
like better rhythm ya know.
- [Lady 2] Right. Cause
they're really good dancers.
- I mean, apparently
they have like bigger...
- Oh, way bigger penises. Right?
- I guess that's because of Africa.
- [Lady 2] Yeah. Like I feel
like they're just, they're
really, really with you in the moment.
Like if they're going to be with you,
they're in the here and now.
- [Lady 1] Exactly. Exactly.
Because they know that they
basically have no future.
Think about it.
- Its so sad.
- [Lady 1] Think about it.
- I do feel like they treat
their women with just like a
little bit more compassion ya know.
- [Lady 1] All about
respect and stuff because
their dads were never around.
- [Lady 2] Oh right.
And they also have a lot of
time on their hands because even
if they have kids, they
never go visit them.
- [Lady 1] Oh. Please. Totally.
Baby daddy. That's a thing.
- Oh. That's on the dictionary now
because of black people.
- See? Seriously,
apparently black guys just
know how to please white women. Right.
Just like way more than white men.
- Oh, well, It's probably in their blood
because they're used to
pleasing their white masters.
- [Lady 1] Law of the jungle right?
- [Lady 2] Yeah totally.
- [Lady 1] I am so desperate
to find out for myself.
- [Lady 2] Me too
- Right?
- Okay. I'm gonna go to the bathroom and I
swear to you. If there's
a black guy back there,
I'm going to blow it.
- [Lady 2] Get it.
- So unrelated, I now
have to go to the bathroom
because I've been drinking coffee all day.
So I will be back in a little while.
- Well you know what,
let, let me go first.
I'll be about, 30 seconds.
- Oh, I hit my penis there.
- I'm sorry. I don't have any money, sir.
- Ok
- What up homies
- Welcome to
- [Together] Cunnilingus class
I'm Shaboost Michael
I'm T-Ray Tombstone.
- And we're here to teach y'all.
- [Together] How to go
down on bitches right.
- Now bitches ain't being
satisfied so check it.
- Quit [BEEP] on that
clitoris so damn hard.
- Bitches don't like that nonsense.
- That's like putting the tip
of your penis in a vacuum.
- [Together] Y'all need
to chill on the clitoris.
- Go around that bidness.
- That's like a button made
of a million penis tops.
- Now every bitch like her cunnilingus
a little bit different.
- Vaginas are like snowflakes.
- Snowflakes is different.
Learn yo bitches snowflake
- Ask yo bitch what she want
- [Together] Then do what she says.
- Some bitches like it in a circle.
- Some bitches like it up and down.
- Some bitches like it hard.
- Some bitches like it soft.
- [Together] Communicate with yo bitches.
- Make the alphabet with yo tongue.
- A, B, C, D.
- And if she grab your hair like she gonna
pull yo damn head off?
Stick with that letter.
I'm talking about BB (blathers).
- Well DDDD (blathers).
- [Together] Vaginas deserve respect.
- You don't want someone stepping
around your little homie.
(Imitates yelping)
- You with the hat.
- Yo.
- How you like your BJs.
- Damn, dawg, all the time.
- Shut the [BEEP] up.
That's cause penises is
easy and vaginas is hard.
- [Together] They're confuuuusssing.
- Imagine there was an explosion
at the envelope factory.
Flaps everywhere. A world of flaps.
- You need to lick away out the factory.
- But every bitch's flaps is different.
- Learn your bitch's particular flaps.
- Flaps be
- [Together] crazzzyyyyy
- Every flap need to be listened to.
- And then you will get
out of the factory alive.
Stay down there.
- [Together] Plan your
breathing like you're swimming.
- You gotta be talking about -
- [Together] Stroke, stroke, breathe.
Stroke, stroke, breathe.
- (Panting)
- Alright, let's take a five minute break.
- And when we come back,
we gonna talk about warming
your bitches up before you get busy.
- And how to last for more
than two damn minutes.
- Take a peach and practice.
- [Crosstalk] Practice on a
peach, practice, practice,
practice.
- Oh, I think it's going to work.
- 30 down 3 billion to go.
- (Sinister laughter)
- It's a weird one.
Nothing out of place. No murder weapon.
- And no motive. There's just a couple
lying dead in their bed.
- The proof is always
out there, detectives.
You just have to know
where to find the pudding.
- Excuse me, sir.
You can't be here. This
is the crime scene.
- Samwell. It's okay.
He's the greatest sex crime
investigator in history.
If it isn't detective Chuck Vaughn.
- Detective Sally Ferguson.
- We could use a genius right now.
- Tom Samwell.
- What have we got, Samwell?
- Well, Vaughn we've got
ourselves a hard case here.
All we've got is--
- Two bodies, both dead, naked, one man,
one woman in the bed, two
scented candles by the nightstand
- How did you--
- Shh.
- No sign of forced entry.
He loved the way they smelled.
(Sniffing)
He wanted to cross the threshold
the way they had on their
wedding day.
(sighs)
You dirty dog.
He would have experienced
that pleasure right here.
(Unzips)
(Yells loudly in pleasure)
(Zips back up)
Anniversary. The couple
was together for a while,
wanted to spice things up.
Check the date on the photograph.
- Vaughn's right. Today was
their 15th wedding anniversary.
This is huge.
- And, what the [BLEEP] was that?
You just pulled your dick out
and started jerking off at the
crime scene.
- Samwell, he's the best there
is. By putting himself in the
perpetrators mindset
he's able to solve crimes
that involve sex.
Bag this up.
- Some call it a blessing.
It's more like a curse.
- Is that what it feels like?
(Sniffing)
- Threesome.
Oh you wanted to see them, didn't you?
You wanted to watch.
25 feet from the bedroom,
across from the kitchen.
You didn't want to see
their flesh yet, did you?
No, he stood right here.
(Unzips)
(Yells loudly in pleasure)
- Oh, come on.
- (Continues yelling)
Role play gone wrong. Check the logs.
- We've got a bloody fire poker.
We've got our murder weapon.
- Um, why do your revelations
require masturbation?
- Why do kittens require milk?
- No, not the same thing.
- Hey, hey, he's the
most brilliant goddamned
detective I know. Put your ego aside and
give Vaughn his space.
- My ego? We've got captain pudpuller
flinging his fluids all
over the crime scene.
- Wait. He knew them.
They were close. So close, too close.
He, he,
I think he knew the house.
Why,
what did you want you sick bastard?
You wanted to see what he
saw everyday, only closer.
Closer,
he was close to home.
(Yells loudly in pleasure)
There is our man.
- All right, let's go get him. Go. Go.
- Vaughn, that was amazing.
I'm sorry that I doubted you.
Your methods are unorthodox,
but I cannot argue with your results.
- No hard feelings.
- Uh no, Nope.
Not going to do that.
- I wake up next to this guy and as usual,
I don't even know his name.
I'm trying to get dressed
quickly and get out of there
before he wakes up. But I
can't find my underwear.
I look everywhere, but
I just can't find them.
And then it hits me.
I had left them at another
guy's apartment earlier that
night.
And that's when I knew I had a problem.
(Applause)
- Thanks for sharing, Sky.
Well,
I noticed a lot of new faces
this evening and I'm so glad
you all came.
And I want you to know that
this is a safe place to share.
So if you want to tell us your story,
there'll be no judgment.
- Sure. I'll go.
Hi. Y'all my name's Wendell.
And I am in fact, a sexual addict.
- [Together] Hi Wendell.
- And what brings you here Wendell?
- Well, you know my life
sexually speaking
is crazy
and I just want to find
one single solitary
person to spend the rest of
my life with just one, just one.
- So do you feel like your
addiction is too much to handle
right now?
- Duh. I mean, it's been crazy y'all.
With me, the nastier, the
better. I'm a dirty dog.
Try everything.
All the fixings. Tantric, much like sting.
All the bells and whistles. You name it.
I've dones't it
- And when would you say you
hit rock bottom, Wendell?
- When it got slippery outside my shower.
On the floor, outside my shower.
Oh.
I hit rock bottom sexually,
probably last night, last night.
- Do you think that you could tell us
what happened, Wendell?
- Yeah, let's see. Uhh
it's just like any other night
I had ordered a large pie
pepperoni, pineapple, cheesy
crust, some cheesy bread
on the side. Cut to 30 min later.
Pizza parlor sent over a
delicious lady delivery person.
Body 10, face 10.
That's my weakness.
So I invited her inside,
opened up the box.
It was hot. Devoured the
first slice lickety-split,
crust first. Second slice
didn't stand a chance.
Ate the tip of that bitch first,
washed it down with a pop.
Then I got nasty with the cheesy
bread and my heart started
pounding harder than usual
curse. Ker-slunk. Ker-slunk.
Moved onto the third slice--
- What about the girl?
- What girl?
Oh, the girl.
Yeah, she was there too.
And I invited her into my
boudoir, AKA "the stabbin' cabin".
We disrobed one another.
I touched her on her genitalia,
she touched me on my man-italia and that's
when I hit it. Sexually, of course,
upstairs, downstairs,
all around the town stairs as you do.
And by then it was
just another night and I mean
oil everywhere and
sauce all over me.
- Sauce?
- Oh yeah. That's my word for it.
Ejaculate.
Anyhoo I'm so distraught because I feel
vulnerable and I don't know.
I just
feel like anyone could
take advantage of me
right now a-ny-one.
Okay. Let's see what the
blondes have to say first.
- Well, thank you Wendell, um, thank you
for sharing. It's actually our time today.